le mercredi c'est culture mauricie
bonsoir 5 est rien on va parler ce soir
du grand méchant loup et oui le cinéma
c'est du cinéma par les musiques avec
sanseverino vous l'avez rencontré amour
pas exactement et on continue à parler
on continue à parler musique et pour
cela nous recevons michael lukasz
bonsoir alors vous représentez le cri ce
soir alors le criquet ce que c'est c'est
le centre de ressources heavy noah pour
la musique en fait c'est un réseau de
trompes de structure sur le département
salle de concert studios de répétition
salle de formation but de formation qui
agissent dans le domaine des musiques
dites actuelles secteur amplifiées voilà
c'est un peu tous les domaines dont le
résumé exactement va merci donc en fait
vous travaillez donc à la promotion donc
de ses musiques et à l'accompagnement de
projets et ce soir vous venez nous
présenter votre sélection
2013-2014 pour les yves live c'est ça
mais alors il live de quoi s'agit-il
kessel alors il a cité un dispositif
d'accompagnement artistique
effectivement pendant pendant un an on
va suivre donc les neuf dont on va
parler parler ensuite c'est un
dispositif qui est un peu anciens
maintenant ça fait 20 ans qu'on
travaille là dessus c'est la quinzième
édition a laissé un dispositif qui va
proposer de l'accompagnement artistique
il ya du travail en résidence en
répétition tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
par rapport à la scène mais aussi tout
un volet sur la structuration
administrative du projet un côté aussi
promotionnelle de la diffusion au
concert donc vous mettez en fait à
disposition des groupes que vous allez
sélectionnés et donc on va aller on va
les évoquer finalement des moyens
humains techniques structures c'est ça
notre notre notre coeur de métier c'est
le concert on a les infrastructures donc
on a des choses à proposer de manière
structurelle
et donc on met ça au service de ces
groupes effectivement alors ces groupes
ce sont des groupes qui sont amateurs ou
quelle est leur leurs projets quel est
l'objectif pour alors on a des amateurs
des professionnels c'est-à-dire amateurs
dans le sens où ils ne vivent pas de ça
mais effectivement le
l'objectif d'yves live en fin de garde
yves live s'adresse à des groupes qui se
donne les moyens dans la restructuration
de devenir professionnel donc c'est à
dire de tirer leurs revenus de la
musique qui d'accord alors rappelez nous
le principe de cet accompagnement sur
l'année on a dit à mise à disposition de
de différents moyens ok alors ces
groupes du coup vous les avez
sélectionné je suppose avec des critères
très précis parce que là vous leur
mettez à disposition des choses
importantes c'est pas pour tout le monde
de choisir il ya combien au départ qu'il
y en avait 100
qui a globalement je dois dire que nous
on est très surpris c'est une centaine
de candidatures avec globalement de très
bon niveau à chaque fois alors justement
comment s'est fait cette sélection c'est
un travail acharné de longues
discussions non en gros donc c'est un
comité de sélection qui se constitue
donc le comité sélection est composée de
gens qui travaillent dans les lieux du
réseau du crime il se trouve c'est des
représentants de chacun des lieux c'est
ça alors tous les lieux ne sont pas
représentés c'est à la volonté de chacun
ou aussi peut-être chacun mais mais en
tout cas dans les fêtes c'est ça
le fait est que ces composée à 90% de
programmateur pour ça que j'essaie
toujours auprès des groupes pour qu'ils
postulent au moins un peu de visibilité
pour eux et ensuite on a trois temps de
sélection
donc on demande au groupe un dossier
nous envoyer des morceaux et c'est donc
les deux premiers moments sont sont des
discussions liées à sa ces écoutes de
morceaux à l'épluchage un peu des
dossiers et ensuite on a un troisième
temps
qu'il aille sur deux jours où on a
auditionné les vues en entretien une
présélection de 14 groupes dans au café
de la plage à manger de la
celle-saint-cloud des vrais entretiens
gauche
non justement c'est bien que j'ai dit ça
parce qu'on leur dit bien qu'on n'est
pas là pour les piéger l'idée dans ces
entretiens c'est vraiment de jauger la
motivation et la disponibilité du groupe
par amour à ça on va leur demander c'est
pas du 24 24 mais on va leur demander
certaines choses pendant une année on a
besoin d'avoir des gens disponibles face
à nous ça rejoint aussi cette volonté de
se professionnaliser cet avis est ce que
c'est leur propre roger numéro 1 parlons
donc voilà on veut jauger un peu en face
de nous que tout le monde et decker dans
le groupe et va dans le même sens leur
projet numéro 1 donc on y fait c'est un
critère que vous sélectionnez vous allez
en effet évalué au moment que ces
entretiens il ya d'autres critères je
crois alors il ya un critère de base
très pratique et qu'il faut nous on est
une somme en espèces association pardon
départementale dont qui fait qu' au
moins résident yvelinois adam groupe ça
c'est une condition sinequanone donc
ensuite il ya voilà ces notions de
motivation de disponibilité et puis il
ya évidemment un critère artistique plus
subjectif forcément et donc qui mène à
des discussions acharnées entre les
différents membres du comité mais on est
tous très fiers
neuf groupes sélectionnés cette année
c'est une sélection plutôt éclectique
alors on va parler d'eux je vous donne
quelques noms puis vous vous le dis
comme ça ce que ce que vous en pensez
mais avec une petite définition le bnd
albas alors qu'ici alors bonnes balles
basses crl bassement
ça
c'est un trio en fait guitare basse
batterie en fait autour de ben ben qu'un
artiste mauritanien qui arrive de
mauritanie finck a beaucoup bourlingué
depuis notamment en espagne etc
on est dans la musique du monde musique
il veut tout dire et pas grand chose
finalement donc lui il aime bien qu'on
dise que c'est du blues du désert voilà
les marais du blues
ils ont une toute particularité c'est
vrai qu'ils collaborent parfois avec les
prisons fin des concerts en prison alors
nous parce qu'on a on a une
collaboration avec le spip 78 dont qui
mène de l'action culturelle dans les
prisons les yvelines a effectivement
récemment et j'étais avec eux notamment
hier il était à la prison de bois d'arcy
il ya quinze jours j'étais avec eux à la
maison d'arrêt pour femmes de versailles
effectivement d'accord alors ensuite on
a à nicole croome oui alors ça c'est
assez spécial s'il ne rencontre du dub
et du métal sa combinaison pour
l'habitude d'entendre non pour les
puristes ya un groupe américain qui
s'appelle deux trios et en fait ce
groupe est né de deux c'est parce que
ces trois gars là ont vu ce groupe là
sur scène ils ont la révélation donc
effectivement on est sur quelque chose
de d'assez aérien et puis des fois plus
tendues avec le côté métal dont grosses
guitares qui envoie mes blessures du
dossier de l'instrumental c'est que de
l'instrumental
d'accord une cloque alors qu'une claque
alors là je regarde des petites fiches
mais annoncé un duo c'est donc batterie
et guitare et étonnamment ton jeudi
étonnamment parce que c'est assez rare
moi je trouve à la batterie on a une
femme déjà on n'a pas beaucoup de filles
dans les gros joujou général c'est vrai
là donc c'est un c'est un duo voilà on
est en train de les effectifs guitare
demi batterie et jenny donc qui est à
cette batterie re chante beaucoup
aurélien chantre de plus en plus donc
ils chantent tous les deux mais voilà
donc duo rock
vraiment bercé par parler les groupes
comme sonic youth et voilà d'accord
alors ensuite on a lolito alors lolito
il ya deux chanteuses étaient là on a un
groupe de fidèles que faire et guitare
et batterie également oui c'est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un power pop c'est à
dire qu'on est on est dans la pop là on
est vraiment dans voilà dans quelque
chose d'assez fun da c'est donc avec
avec
les deux demoiselles devant qui sont
auchan dont une qui est aussi à la base
la deuxième qui parfois est au clavier
et puis derrière on à la
guitare batterie qui est sur le tube
mais voilà on est vraiment un truc assez
festif aussi coiffé d'accord moi je vous
propose pour qu'on est là on a vu
quelques images on n'a pas beaucoup de
sens peut-être qu'on regarde une petite
compilation de ses premiers gros pain
il
m
je
n'ai pas m
mais on est très fier on est très
content de cette sélection alors michael
douglas ont continué ce mini cette
attention parce qu'il reste encore
quatre groupes à l'hermine a encore
alors encore c'est ce trio c'est un trio
pour la petite info il ya deux groupes
deux frères cavenaghi là il ya douze ans
dans un autre groupe voilà on est sur un
côté groovy voilà c'est à dire de
l'électro mais je vous live avec des
instruments ambiance dancefloor to dance
floor trop disco alors après on change
de registre avec dirty is ou dirty joue
donc c'est un groupe hip hop ils se
qualifient de de festif et décalé c'est
ça c'est pas du tout un groupe qui a des
revendications politiques c'est pas un
groupe qui se la joue gangsta non plus
on est pour ceux qui connaissent dans un
espèce de rencontres entre les svinkels
saïan supa crew c'est des mecs qui
techniquement nous ont bluffés c'est un
super forts qui sont qu'à doha blanc + 4
même si un dj et et puis voilà ils ont
un univers toit de ce zoo avec les
animaux
et enfin alors je dis pas et enfin il
reste deux on a bazar et bémol qu'on a
déjà qu'on connaît nous déjà ici sur le
plateau l'euro c'est plutôt chanson jazz
swing c'est ça et puis c'est ce modèle
encore de deux groupes tout terrain
c'est à dire que depuis peu ils sont
intermittents et je dis ça parce qu'il
joue aussi bien sur les scènes un peu
institutionnalisée où les belles scènes
qu'on peut connaître et en même temps
c'est des musiciens qui pour vivre parce
que vous me dites que ça qu'on fait le
métro il pourrait s'en passer maintenant
mais il aime san qui continue à jouer le
même dans le métro il joue dans la rue
l'été qu'ils aiment être confronté un
public tout le temps d'accord et enfin
donc là pour le coup c'est le dernier
ses highlights alors n'est plus sûr de
la musique new wave alors on est encore
dans de la pop au sens large un mail
menton voix lolito et et encore on
essaie un peu différent voilà
donc avec le côté un peu new wave heures
on y sent quelque chose de très
sophistiqué très aérien avec beaucoup de
la santé c'est vraiment très très très
haut niveau et candidature on arrive à
des niveaux moins bons professionnels et
on regarde des quatre derniers groupes
d
et
du ciel je nie pas les écoles
qui vont
quand même tu sais c'est de la balle
et
on peut re
nir de tout sens est reparti très loin
mire de loin sans être partie du tout
alors voilà donc les neuf groupes pour
la prochaine saison donc d'yves life
vous avez peut-être en un mot certains
des éditions précédentes ont réussi à
percer effectivement les plus récents va
dire seller d'anna kid qui remplissent
nos élites entier maintenant voilà qu'on
embrasse d'un acquis les blérots de
ravel debout sur le zinc et dancer voilà
et puis après beaucoup de carrière de
musicien personnel on a des missions
maintenant qu'il veut johnny hallyday
aujourd'hui on sent que le niveau
augmente d'année en année un clairement
ouais on est jeudi trèbes le fait à
chaque fois il s'est plus en plus dure
moins de temps je m'en réjouis mais
merci de nous avoir présenté ses gros
merci beaucoup